[Music]
what is going on everybody and welcome
to a tech review of the new oculus rift
s headset so I've had this headset now
for a little over a day I've put in a
few hours but I'm no stranger to the
oculus rift headsets I've had them since
the dk2 I've also got the cb1 headset
and now this one so why did I get this
one when I have the CV one well the big
thing for me was the the biggest latest
change and that is the inside-out
tracking so this is a tracking camera
you've got two down here and you've got
one on each side of the oculus and this
is so you don't have to deal with the
room sensor things anymore so you used
to have to place these get an extra one
if you want a room scale so you need to
like three of these placed around room
there are not the most pretty things to
sit around they'd get bumped or whatever
and it was it was really annoying and
there was some occlusion issues that you
would get from time to time as well and
so anyways this sounded really cool to
me this has had a lot of mixed feelings
and opinions as far as whether or not
inside out tracking is going to work but
if you ask me that's has to be the
future of VR headsets so I think this is
a move in the right direction now the
other major change is like the headband
I mean like this is like the most
hardcore headband yet so to put this in
perspective let me show you the DK 2
headset bang this was your headset a few
straps and stuff and it would like
always fall down your head and it was
super super annoying then we had the C
v1 headset which was a pretty good
improvement a little better more rigid
and stuff like that but this still
wanted to fall down your face like if I
put my finger here it still really badly
wants to fall now with the latest it's
actually quite nice if I if I put my
finger on the headband it actually wants
to balance like it doesn't actually
necessarily want to fall right down
if I tilt forward does want to fall town
but the balance feels a lot better and
playing with it I actually really liked
it you have to actually pay attention
like my natural tendency when I put on
the rift is to put it like a little a
little high on my forehead because then
it kind of slowly falls down into place
whereas this headset I actually found
myself kind of pulling it down to get
things to line up again so that's pretty
cool
so I'm so far I'm pretty happy this like
loosens and tightens and there's a
button here on the bottom that extends
or retracts this for glasses people so
mine's all the way out because I have
glasses it does not solve your problems
so I think over time these lenses will
still get scratched if you're wearing
glasses you can buy like prescription
lenses to put in there or you can I've
got a 3d printer now so I've actually
I'm actually just going to print some of
these and then I bought some lenses from
xeni if anybody is curious about that
you can ask in the description I found
somebody put something on Thingiverse
pretty cool anyways so yeah so that's
the headset now the controller so these
are the new controllers here really the
biggest change from the CV one is like
this little hoop thing is now at the top
of the controller which as a subtle
benefit that I'm not really sure this is
what they were going for but now when
you put the controllers down like you
can actually set them down whereas this
is one of the older this is the CV 1
controller there was like no good way to
put these down like you could sort of do
that but it still would like roll around
these just nice bang done I love it
they're also a little fatter so they
feel better in your hand
so I'm actually I think these are better
it's just when you have this over your
face I'm so used to finding the hoop and
then like slipping my hand through the
hoop I go it's just been become second
nature for me so with these it's like
the actual opposite and I find myself
getting very confused when I'm in VR
like trying to get these freaking on my
hands I keep trying to do this and I'm
like wait what's going on Oh anyway I
just have to learn the new the new grips
now but otherwise everything's pretty
much the same
in terms of like the buttons and all
that no big difference so now in
playtime I use my VR headsets for really
two major types of games I play a
driving simulator type game so it's like
I'm just in a cockpit or like elite
dangerous which again you're just it's
like a space fighting game and again
you're in a cockpit so you're really not
moving around that much and then the
other games that I play are like FPS
games like first-person shooter games
which is what really drove me to this
headset because the room scale stuff is
very difficult with these first-person
shooter games so I've got a sunroom that
I like to play in but setting that
sunroom up to be
I can't just dedicate that to a VR room
so having it with inside out tracking
what sounded like a really cool option
so I've done that I've played probably
maybe one to two hours in onward with
the new rift s and I would say it's
pretty darn good I don't really have too
many issues with that their only thing
that I've noticed is sometimes the the
for whatever reason like when you start
lining up the two controllers this one
will get occluded which is not too
surprising because the tracking is right
on the headset so if you're like lining
up your sights you might actually
occlude the the controller's now with
onward I mean this is a brand new
headset and the way that they're doing
the tracking with with your hands and
stuff is in a way that doesn't really
suit this it works and it actually works
way better than I thought it would
already but I know that they're working
on updates already to fix that now now
comes really the biggest issue I've had
with this headset and that is this top
camera I'm so I'm using this in my son
room and my son room has ten skylights
and as the Sun is coming over the Sun
shines through the skylights and if it
hits this which it often does depending
on look where I'm standing in that room
if it hits that and blinds of this
camera everything just goes haywire and
my hands are all over the place which
makes no sense but if this gets blinded
it's over even though like my controller
like this isn't even see
my controllers it's my controllers are
supposed to be seen by like these mostly
but for whatever reason if this gets
blinded it's done so that's kind of
annoying and and again I don't know if
that's gonna get fixed by the changes
coming to onward or not but right now I
really just can't play when the Sun is
like right high in the sky yeah so
that's kind of annoying the other thing
is like this this kind of headset was
kind of had just in general a lot of
mixed reviews with the inside out
tracking and then the screen they
actually changed to a slightly inferior
screen type and then also went from
ninety Hertz refresh rate to 80 Hertz
refresh rate and these two changes had
people up in arms and stuff and I'm
gonna be honest with you guys for a
while I was considering buying one of
those the vive pro because I wanted to
better more crisp screen but the price
of the vive pro with like the stupid
base station and the headset and
everything just kind of I wasn't really
so sure about it and but I will say if I
bought the vive pro I spent $1000 on a
headset and this was the upgrade I got I
would be happy the the screen change
here first of all there's way less
screen door effects going on and just
the clarity of the screen is I I would
call that a massive improvement I'm
super happy with it I wouldn't say my
picture quality or color or a contrast
for anything is noticeably worse but
immediately when I put that headset on
the first thing I noticed was holy crap
this is super clear I just I could you
could read text thing edges were
actually edges and not blurs huge huge
improvement I'm super excited about this
and at this price point again I just
don't think you can do any better set up
was a breeze you really do just like
plug it in hit next next next next next
the controllers came paired so like I
didn't have to pair the controllers the
room scale setup is awesome so because
we have these cameras you can enable
this like pass through and that's
another huge
benefit is like so like while I'm
playing in room scale if I just double
tap this oculus button it turns on
pass-through so I can see around my room
that I'm playing in and to see where I
am because sometimes you you know you're
a little lost in the urge to pull off
the headset and see where we are can be
pretty strong sometimes they're like
sometimes between levels or something
you might want to change where you're
standing so anyway just being able to
double tap this see where you are double
tap it back get back in the game awesome
and then setting up the rim scale with
this it's also a breeze because you just
double tap this or I'm sorry we've set
the RHIB scale you don't have to hit
this you're just in the room and then
you just paint your area and again what
a great idea I mean it's just so simple
and like resetting it up or changing
things is unbelievably simple I'm a huge
fan I'm sold on this thing that like I
say the only issue I'm having is when
sunlight just destroys this camera but
other than that pretty cool the refresh
rate honestly nobody was getting 90
frames a second if you say you were stop
it I've been playing VR on the worst
graphics card lately has been the 1080
Ti but I've played it on the Titan r-tx
cards I was never getting 90 frames a
second okay so stop it 80 frames a
second is totally fine if you're getting
80 frames a second go by like a PI max
8k or something anyway yeah awesome
headset really happy with it inside out
tracking definitely the future we have a
few little things to change and to fix
and I'm really excited to see the
changes that onward puts out to see if
that fixes my occlusion issues and it
might even fix this top sensor issue
that would be really nice when they
change Dax that's what goes haywire is
like my character doesn't but my hands
get all messed up because of this top
sensor so we'll see how that goes and
maybe I'll post a follow-up at some
point but my initial thoughts on this
headset is yeah it's amazing
III love it I love it so very cool very
excited to continue playing with it very
happy with it so anyways
sponsored in any way either I will put a
link in the description to the headset
on Amazon now and if you are interested
you could buy it through that link and
I'll get a little bit of a kickback from
Amazon but I really just bought it for
myself and I'm super happy so anyways
those are my thoughts I'll see you guys
later